we are taking calls at 607 eight-30 47
50 let's go to our next caller from the
three-30 area code caller what's your
name and where are you calling from
oh hi my name is uh my name is Alan from
I'm from Cleveland Ohio great what's on
your mind oh I was kind of kind of
wondering what you thought about people
like you know like dave rubin or like
secular talk on youtube and that sort of
idea of like of aggressive verse
progressive left and like the idea of
being having like a left social agenda
while having like a libertarian or like
a left economic agenda versus like a
libertarian social identity a and women
and kyle kolinsky are the same i in fact
they've kind of been involved in a
twitter battle or they were a couple of
weeks ago that i was watching but I
guess you're not saying that they're the
same right no I've just seen a lot of
sort of his YouTube video both of their
YouTube do sort of criticizing um you
know things like um I think affirmative
action was one of them and like when
they let that sikh guy in the military
where his uh where the head where that
he wears and he was kind of complaining
that if you're going to let religious
people wear the head where you have to
let other people wear head wear just be
like you can't just exclude religious
people you only mean yeah I haven't seen
those so I can't I mean I think that the
more interesting thing you're getting at
is this idea of overlapping philosophies
where someone might have left economic
views but libertarian social views etc I
mean I think the more interesting
question is in what areas is there
overlap between for example libertarian
social politics and progressive social
politics I think that there's
significant overlap in many areas
although sometimes for different reasons
right like the reasons why a libertarian
and a progressive might have the same
point of view on a social issue would
not necessarily be the same from one
side it might be out of out of a sort of
egalitarian perspective whereas on the
libertarian side it may be from a right
and suggest Liberty perspective or the
same question
could apply to why do some libertarians
and some fiscal conservative Republicans
have overlapping views on some economic
policy not for the same reasons
necessarily so I think that that is is a
very interesting angle to explore we've
been talking about it quite a bit and
you know what's interesting is that the
Trump era actually may open the door to
many of these strange political
bedfellows to actually work together
because right approval does not improve
it within the next six months I would
suggest you know just this week we had
Lindsey Graham and John McCain and other
prominent Republicans being really
critical of what's going on with him in
Russia you may actually see more
Republican and progressive alliances
formed at least around some issues right
yeah and I was kind of also wondering
like um like for example specifically
like affirmative action how you think
like some people think that it's
necessary to sort of you know obviously
during like the the civil rights era or
something it was necessary to put forth
those types of ideas for a temporary
amount of time or you know whatever it
may be and do you think that there are
like better alternatives to that sort of
like it's almost like an authoritarian
thing to do you know and I wonder if you
think that there's like better
alternatives or if the government in
that place in there or if you agree with
those types of programs well I I you
know there's a contingent that says
affirmative action is racism affirmative
action is no different than saying black
people can't go to the same restaurants
as white people I reject that all
together what I do think is really
valuable when we think about the need
for affirmative action and I've used a
monopoly game example to talk about this
before I won't repeat it now but but you
could it's widely available online you
can check that out
what I think would be more powerful
would be if we can work together to get
to a point where affirmative action is
just demonstrably no longer necessary in
any way and I think that that right
you're going to get more disagreement
from left and right and libertarian etc
which is well first of all
what needs to be done and secondly how
should it be done I think that's where
you're going to have more conflict among
different political stripes so to speak
right right
all right listen thank you so much for
the call I appreciate very very
important issues there and we're going
to continue talking about them